it's midnight and Lincoln Hall is at the
point of no return after 22 years his
chance to summit Everest has arrived
again after four days of solid climbing
he heads into the Death Zone where
survival depends upon speed only 3,000
feet below the summit Lincoln will try
to ascend and return as quickly as
possible the gruelling 18-hour day
but suddenly Lincoln comes face-to-face
with yet another victim of Everest
brutal conditions it is the body of
British climber David sharp it was quite
shocking
his body was literally frozen solid of
the 11 deaths during this climbing
season the most famous is David sharp 10
days earlier sharp had crawled into a
shallow cave it was his third attempt to
climb Everest but his method was
extremely risky
he had a minimalist approach to climbing
he had no Sherpa support he had no real
contact with other expedition members
because he didn't have a radio when he
was discovered dying nobody even knew
who he was he was very much alone as
many as 40 climbers walked past David
sharp as he lay dying concealed in the
darkness most didn't see him those who
did see him assumed that he was resting
or already dead but David sharp didn't
die that night next morning he was still
alive
now visible in the daylight the
returning climbers began to notice him
it was very a very tragic situation
climbers coming back from the summit the
coldest night of the season 11 cases of
serious frostbite that night alone it
was the worst night of the season to be
out in the elements and that's when
David Sharpe is dying the media reacted
swiftly to the news that David Sharpe
was left to die David Sharpe ran into
trouble on the mountain and he is passed
by a number of climbers 40 other
climbers passed by mountaineer David
sharp as he lay dying as commercial
mountaineering made climbing a
remarkably heartless pursuit criticism
all the more stinging since it comes
from Sir Edmund Hillary
the reason david sharpe could not be
rescued was because it was physically
impossible to do so he could not walk
and the reality of being at extreme
altitude is that everything effectively
weighs four times as much because as you
don't have the oxygen in your system to
make your muscles work so to be able to
lift a dead body or a newly dead body is
just impossible there was just no chance
of bringing him down at all no chance